go okay good great yeah great to be here
so I'll be telling you a little a little
bit about our recent work we've been
doing on using random projections for
probabilistic inference and I want to
start by giving you an idea of the kind
of problems that we can use that we can
use this technique son a little bit of
motivation so we've seen that in the
past few years say I has made a lot of
progress in a lot of exciting
application domains we build things like
the Watson system we've made a lot of
progress in speech recognition things
like a machine translation now think
about the skype nowadays you know you
can speak to it can recognize your voice
translate into a different language and
synthesize the voice at the other end
image classification and think about
alpha go you know this system there but
in the lease really accents played
really well that's pretty good it
doesn't thalia pretty well my wife can
speak to my parents in italy and they
more or less conspicuous I many years
and couldn't do it and alpha go is also
you know it managed to beat the one of
the leading go players a few months ago
so lots of lots of successes and one of
the key techniques that sort of were
used to build these systems is a
supervised learning so this idea that in
order to build this complex systems one
possible approach is to try to train a
machine to solve this task by providing
a lot of examples on how to solve it so
for example if you want to do image
classification what we can do is we can
take a complex model like maybe a neural
network you can show it a lot of
examples of images with the
corresponding labels like showing images
of dogs cats honey badgers and then by
checking what kind of predictions the
machine does the model does we can sort
of back propagate arrows we can
fine-tune the way the system gets better
and better and eventually we can develop
the state-of-the-art systems that work
very well in practice and there has been
three major trends that made all these
recent success is possible the first one
is that the use of these very complex
and high-capacity models like deep
neural net for
works the second one is just the
improvement in hardware that made
training these models possible but the
third one was really the availability of
very large labeled training data sets so
for example imagenet it's a huge
collection of labeled images like
millions of images you see here some
examples and it is really crucial to
have this kind of training data in order
to train these systems because now
there's a lot of variability in images
you can see there are all sort of things
that can change even within us the same
class and so in order to train a system
to to be robust and to work well in
practice you really need to provide a
lot labeled examples to make the system
work well in practice and the challenge
of course is that labeling is expensive
it took a lot of effort to collect this
kind of data set and so and then the key
question is whether there is there are
ways in which we can use the unlabeled
data say maybe you have one of these
recent data sets like several hundred
thousand photos of celebrities but let's
assume that we don't have any labels
about them like we don't know who these
people are we don't know anything about
what's actually in the picture we don't
know we cannot ask humans to label for
us whether people how the gases or not
what kind of I call or a kind of hair
color or gender or anything so is that
something that we can do using these
kind of unlabeled data sets and one
natural thing to do is to try to
construct a model that essentially
discovers the structure in the data and
one such model would be try to construct
a probability distribution over images
that essentially captures the structure
in these images that we can use to train
it so probability distribution of our
images that puts high probabilities on
images that look like human faces of
celebrity faces and why is this useful
well if you have such a model then you
can do all sort of interesting tasks you
can for example two unsupervised feature
learning so you might be able to
discover features automatically that
then you can use later on to do
supervised classification tasks or you
know you can do
other kind of probabilistic reasoning
tasks like remove noise from images you
can complete missing part in images you
can improve the resolution are all sort
of interesting things that you can do if
you can construct such a model so
probability distribution that such that
if you sample from this probability
distribution you're going to get images
that look like say human faces so how
can we do this well one natural way to
do it is to consider a latent variable
the latent variable model we've seen
this in the talks yesterday on
probabilistic programming this idea that
we can view computer vision as the
inverse procedure of computer graphics
so the idea is that we're going to have
a model with two types of variables
there's going to be some variables that
we observe and these are their images so
pixels and we assume that there's going
to be some latent variables some the
capture essentially all the factors of
variations that can happen in an image
these are things we don't get to see
because they are the images that we have
access to are not labeled and just as a
toy example we might have things like
maybe the ethnicity of the person which
then my effect is I color the hair color
the pose of the person the gender so if
you had all these hidden features of the
of the image then it would be a
relatively straightforward or easier at
least to actually generate an image that
satisfies this this kind of condition
these Velvets come from so in this this
is like a toy model you know you the
kind of techniques that i'm going to
show our we're not going to actually put
a semantic meaning on there on the
variables so we're just going to say
there is some latent structure that we
are going to capture using some latent
variables and we're going to try to
discover it so that's a way to get model
flexibility there are some ways in which
you can try to sort of put a semantic
meaning like you can if you have some
labels that you can try to sort of for
example try to have high mutual
information between some of your hidden
variables and some label that you have
let's see if you have a small number of
images where you have labeled they are
the hair color or something then you can
try to do it but for now we're just
going to assume that
going to try to discover the structure
automatically so how well can this work
so let me show you some examples these
are some images and that you can get
with this kind of system how many of you
think that the images in the first row
are actually generated from a model or
actually a real how many think that
images in the first row are real
there's other they actually generated by
a model the actual image is where these
ones
sigit flip again yeah so these are so
you can see now the images in the first
slide are actually generated from other
these are samples so you basically draw
some random variables based on some
probability just based on this
probability distribution you sample the
Z variables and then you sample the acts
condition on the on the Z and you get
images that look like that and these are
the actual true images so you can see
it's doing a pretty good job I think
like it's almost as good that it can
actually for humans it does make some
mistakes you see like this one for
example has some strange thing on the
forehead but the actual person doesn't
have there's not perfect yeah visit me I
mean you can have a model just memorize
this training data and then you know
maybe adds changes color or something
like that like to so great question yeah
I get to that in the next slide yeah
i'll show you exactly how I'm generating
business and so i'll get to that
question its present the things credit
so good so you can see it's doing a
pretty good job now how am i actually
doing this so the way I'm doing it is
i'm actually doing an in painting task
so what I'm doing is I'm providing the
model a piece of an actual image like in
this case and providing the eyes of the
person and then I'm asking the model
complete the image so for example if I
give them out of these eyes one of these
two is the actual person corresponding
to those eyes the other one is the one
generated by the model and they are
different i actually even the gender is
different this looks like a female i
guess this looks like a meal can you
guess which one is true which one is
generated by the model bottom is true
bottom is true yeah but it it's still
reasonable I think it's doing a decent
job at generating an image so does that
answer your question sort of in terms of
the variation
so because you can imagine something it
basically just store the training data
to the fan looked up you know which
which scene because they're just output
them so it's not now it's on it's on our
test set so it's a separate set of this
model has not seen these pieces of the
images before but it might have seen the
same person because I think the same
it's a data set of celebrities so I
think there are multiple folders of the
same celebrity so it might have seen it
from a different angle sorry that it
didn't remember it's sort of coming up
with new stuff you can see here it's
coming up with a female face instead of
money on things but the fact that it
somehow the two images in the images are
so similar I mean that kind of puzzles
me I don't quite understand how you
generally given what parameters can you
gave you know you know your way if you
know European a 50 year old men even if
you fix the I do so many variations that
I can understand how you get with so
many so few variables so I don't oh I'm
not using those variables that was a toy
model that's not the action mother i'm
using so this is not this is just to
give up my d of how the model this idea
of using latent variables versus
observed variables in afflicted
variables they become semitic what is it
latent variable now we're not late and
very well kept to the pixels I i well
fix it you could but then it's not going
to work well on a new on data piece of
enemies that you haven't seen before so
I could memorize all the training images
but then how is it going to do anything
meaningful on a new image yeah there's
two piles of images yeah the computer
sees pile a for a while does what it
does then from PI OB you pick an image
you crop it yep
pewter and the computer has to fill out
the rest of the chapter that's the task
so there is this synthetic basically
what we see around desire yeah it's
synthetic based on a probability
distribution that we're going to try to
train yeah is it would have been
possible to have the test set have
distinct set of humans maybe I don't
know if it has the labels maybe that
would be interesting actually because
it's possible they may be I has seen the
same person and though it's hard I guess
they confused by detail when we showed
us the real images and the synthetic
ones they seem to be matched in the same
positions yeah so I I did it on purpose
so that they can actually compare them
but when you randomly generated min
image how can I find out okay neck
generic one with a hat for example with
the same color as you wanted and so I
only give it the eyes so it's you see
like this one is generating a female and
this one is generating a male might
start with that the three slider here
when you win the shoulders here the
images the many images receive the same
magenta hat or to add it's probably in
the eyes see that's why it can complete
so for those kind of ice is going to
generate a hat let's see it has seen
that there is a hat there and so it
figured out that i should probably
complete it and they well the image the
actual images like this I didn't great
do a great job it looks more like a
swimming you can but yeah yeah the one
after that so in this example is it fair
to say that the computer knows that
under the nose there should be a mouth
yeah but I think it puts a generic mouth
or the clothes in that example and
there's a photo-realistic mouth sort of
yeah I think that it's hard to say what
exactly it's doing but that probably has
figured out that there is a relationship
between eyes there has to be a mouth
underneath yes yes yes it synthesized
enough yes yeah so I guess another way
to
don't understand how much invoices thing
is given the same set of eyes and runny
hundred times jealousy there is some
variation yeah I don't have them here
unfortunately very sure but this is just
to motivate I can show a different
example where it doesn't work as well
today I'm showing it parts of a bedroom
and I'm asking you to complete the image
of the bedroom so these are the seeds so
you should show it a piece of a bad or
something and you can see this is the
true image that we i cropped it out from
and the samples are a little bit more
this one is a harder problem i think you
see geometric structures and faces yes
it's like there's much more variety like
you see good bad up here i think it's
good and do a great job but doing that
and there are some strange things about
where it pleases windows and curtains
but it's still doing reasonably well and
but again this was just to motivate how
do we actually train these models the
challenge here is that we only get to
see the images we don't get to see all
the values for this latent variables so
one way in which these models are
trained is that while you have a very
complex model with tons of parameters
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to try to find the
parameters that maximize the likelihood
of the training set for those parameters
so mathematically what we have is we
have the X we have a probably a joint
probability distribution between the
visible variables and the hidden mass
which factors in a nice way because it
is this kind of generative process where
you first sample latent variables and
then the visible ones and the goal is
that going to be that of maximizing that
the marginal likelihood of the data when
you marginalize out all this hidden
variables that we don't know the value
of
so if you want to spell it out
completely we have to basically maximize
or the parameters of the model the log
marginal likelihood of each example
where you have to some out all these
factors of variations that we don't know
anything about and the challenge is that
computing these kind of expectations is
very expensive we have seen it in some
of the talks before it effectively
corresponds to computing a very high
dimensional integral and so how these
models are actually training practice is
typically using a variational
approximation where the basic idea is
that we're going to use a tractable
proxy for this intractable a marginal
likelihood so the math is fairly simple
we start with the marginal likelihood
here we multiply and divide by some
probability distribution cube which can
be anything it just has to be non zero
and then what we do is we just apply
Jensen's inequality to bring the
logarithm inside the Sun and we get a
lower bound that way what do we want to
do this because we're going to choose Q
to be simple and if Q is simple then
this is an integral with respect to Q
and so that's something that we can
actually evaluate efficiently if we are
careful about how we choose q
so the picture is something like this
there is the true marginal likelihood of
the data as a function of the parameters
that's hard to compute we cannot do it
so instead we're going to look at a
lower bound which is given by that
Jensen's inequality and of course the
question that you should probably
thinking about is that how good is this
lower bound like I've shown you before
then no matter how you choose q you're
going to get a lower bound but how good
is this is this lower bound like how
close is this red curve to the to the
black curve because ultimately what
we're going to try to do is we're going
to try to optimize the red curve hoping
that we're going to get that we are also
going to optimize the black curve but we
don't really know that unless we know
that these two curves are close to each
other it turns out that you can work out
how tight this bound is and it basically
depends on how far you're approximating
distribution q is from the true
posterior distribution over the hidden
variables given the observed ones so
they're going to get that the lower
bound that we're actually going to
optimize that red curve that I have
before is equal to the true thing but
then there is another piece that we that
depends basically on how well we're
going have we can choose q
so the game then becomes trying to
choose Q so that that bounds gets
becomes as good as possible so we know
that if we choose q to be the actual
posterior / z given x then the bounds
become tight and you can sort of see it
if you plug it in here this quantity
becomes a constant so you can factor it
out and things work out the question is
that we want you to be simple so that we
can evaluate that lower bound and so
sometimes you just cannot do it say if P
the posterior is maybe a mixture of two
gaussians showing here in blue and your
tractable distributions are say Gaussian
distributions here you have like a
single mode you might not be able to
describe that complex object just using
a Gaussian maybe the best you can do is
to pick one of the modes and color that
but that's it because you just cannot do
better because you're approximating
distribution is just too simple
Shh
questions yeah the posterior was
dependent on eggs yes so how much can
you expect them it should be dependent
on X I was just sort of hiding them with
the notation values depending on ideally
you should do that in practice you
typically amortize and you come up with
ways to make it faster in practice but
in theory should be depended on access
so this is basically the whole idea
behind variational inference that is
that you have some complex intractable
probability distribution that you care
about like the posterior distribution or
the hidden variables given the visible
ones you have a family or simple
distributions what you try to do is you
try to find it simple you try to fight a
simple distribution in this set that is
as close as possible to pee we're here
closing is KL divergence particular
iPods if you notice is an eye projection
this is called in information theory
it's called the night projection
information projection because you're
but it's not really projection this is
not really a metric visits it's not
symmetric but they call it I projection
so that's why it's called variational
inference because it's an optimization
problem over functions you're sort of
you have a space of probability
distribution and you're trying to
optimize our dot to minimize this
distance which is not really a distance
between the best approximation and p
you say he's not the distance because
but it's not symmetric k vs t not
symmetric so we're trying to find the
tractable distribution is as close as
possible to be the challenge is that as
we've seen before basically in general
you cannot get any kind of bounds on how
far that optimal approximation is from
be basically if Q is too simple with
respect to P like p is bimodal and Q has
is unimodal you just cannot do much this
is like a standard problem of all the
variational inference methods which you
know there are hundreds of papers
probably more it's a very very powerful
technique that comes from statistical
physics that has been used heavily in in
computer science that is the examination
so what i will show you today hopefully
i have time to go over it is a way to
improve our variational inference
methods by using random projections so
that is that what we're going to do is
at a high level we're going to do is
we're going to start with our complex
intractable model we're going to
randomly project it in a way that
somehow preserves the properties of p
and then but simplifies p so that
intuitively the projection p prime
becomes closer to q and so we can get a
better it's easier to approximate and
then what we do is we take an eye
projection of the random projection of p
and because p prime is simpler this
approximation you can show that becomes
good in some sense and because this
random projection does not lose too much
information you can basically recover
the properties of p with high
probability
questions found on the quality of the I
projection in general in this case you
do you do get a bundle particular after
drowning projection yes I suitably
chosen random projection this is a
little bit just the intuition but that's
sort of that idea that is that if it's
too complex you're going to project it
simplify it to the point where we can
approximate it well without losing too
much information is this done there's
the facts or thing that we're going to
do at the end of the day but that's that
that's the plan what about the
approximation we rightly that is
something that we can control because
the random projection is chosen in a way
that it preserves the information so if
you know something about P prime then
you can recover the properties of P what
are less yeah projection depends on
either p or the family of distributions
this only so it does not depend on p but
it only works if q is sufficiently there
is a technical condition on cue it has
to contain all the degenerate
distributions but it's only use its
so the picture would be something like
this before we were optimizing this
lower bound that was potentially
arbitrarily bad the black curve is the
thing we actually care about so what we
want to get is we want to get some kind
of envelope around the black line that
we can control and we want to get some
new estimate which will be stochastic
but it sort of guaranteed to be
relatively close to the black line which
is the one we hear about so if we
optimized for the green line we're
guaranteed that we're going to do not
very pretty much doing the right thing
because where we are fairly close to the
black line which is the one we care
about the black line remember that's the
march the true marginal likelihood of
the data when you integrate out all the
latent factors of variation
questions before we move on to the
random projections
alright so how do we do the these random
projections so let's go back to the
original problem of computing marginal
probability so as before we are giving
some kind of probability distribution
over let's say two types of variables
some visible some hidden our goal is to
marginalize out all the hidden variables
so I'm just going to forget about the X
for now I'm just going to call this
quantity w is going to be a weight that
we want to some out so let's say that if
we have two factors of variation the
gender and the pose and it can be binary
and this is an easy thing there are only
like four possible assignments each one
will get a non-negative weight given by
this probability and so you just want to
sum up four numbers that's easy and then
of course the catch is that if you have
maybe a hundred latent variables this
becomes defines the sum over a huge
number of terms and so this is generally
intractable to compute so to explain how
this works let me make the simplifying
assumption that W is either 0 or 1 if
the problem is still hard but it's a
little bit easier to explain this goes
back to the model counting that motion
was talking about yesterday if you were
here so let me explain how the problem
work expect looking at an analogy so if
the weight function is either 0 or 1
what we want to do is we basically want
to count the number of configurations of
possible assignments to the Z variables
that have weight one so instead of
looking at that problem we're going to
think about another ghost problem where
we want to count the number of people in
an auditorium and the auditorium has
some structure like it's divided into
rows and columns many seats are empty
some seats are full but the distribution
is very uneven and like people tend to
sit on the back and our goal is going to
be that of computing the total number of
people in the room so the analogy of
course is that auditorium is the search
space the space of all possible
assignments the seat each seat
corresponds to an assignment to this
variables and the occupied seats
correspond to assignments with nonzero
wait so how can you do it how can you
count the number of people in the
auditorium one approach is to of course
to do this brute force you just go
through every seat and you increment the
counter if the seat is occupied simple
its exact but of course it does not
scale if you have big space with a
hundred latent variables you're never
going to be able to do it this way but
better approach is to try to explore the
structure of the space so you can try to
sort of maybe divide space like sections
and then recursively count the number of
peoples in each section we divide it
that way first and then we recursively
count each half and the trick here is
that we can use some smart heuristics
for detecting the entire sections that
are either completely fool or completely
empty so this is a lot faster than brute
force it's still exact but it's sort of
still not scalable because you are still
accounting for every single full seat in
the auditorium so what about the
proximate counting then I Eve approach
is to do sampling yeah is instead of
looking at the whole of the torium what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a small section we're going to count the
number of people in that section and
then we're going to scale it up by a
factor of six there are six sections we
just pick one count the people and
multiply by 6 which is fast as long as
that section is small but as you can
imagine it can be wildly inaccurate like
if there are only very few non empty
seats in the auditorium your chances of
actually getting one of them in your
small sample is going to be extremely
small and so this estimator can have a
huge variance it's not going to work in
practice
so let's try something yeah this
fractional seats and not it could be
very small could be very large you don't
dismiss at least one percent or some
know that otherwise would be easy yeah
that would ease if there is a list yeah
that would be easy but it could be
exponentially smaller so so is there
something different let's try something
distributed coin flipping strategy so
that is like this we're going to try to
count the people in the room so we're
going to start by asking everybody to
raise their hand and then we're going to
go through a protocol that works like
this we're going to have everybody flip
a coin and then if it's it comes up
heads then maybe you keep your hand up
and if it comes up tails then you bring
your head your hand down wherever
forever you you down forever yes and
then we can keep repeating this until
we're left to the point where you know
nobody has his hand up at the end as you
can and then what we're going to return
as your account for the number of people
are going to return to to the number of
rounds that we did this process as you
can imagine that this work well on
average you can sort of see why this
works because an average half of the
people will lower their hand at every
round so if there were an people to
begin with it will roughly take you log
to em rounds to get to the point where
nobody has the hands up so roughly
speaking it works now the challenge is
of course how to make this intuitive
idea concrete and actually get an
algorithm and the guide guarantees so
the first challenge is how to get
configurations to flip coins and how to
get the guarantees and this is the same
as the the idea is the same as what
Moshe was describing yesterday if you
were here it's based on the original
theoretic of work in the complexity
theory literature and there are a number
of implementations of this idea and
different analysis the basic building
block is to use parity constraints to
get to implement this coin flipping
strategy so that is that we have a bunch
of variables like pen in this case and
what we're going to do is we're going to
generate random parity constraints by
adding each variable with probability
one-half so maybe we add variable x1 we
had x3 x4 x 7 x 10 then we randomly pick
a parity like a left a right hand side
for disparity equation and then it turns
out that if you generate the parity
constraint like this each configuration
will satisfy this parity constraint with
probability one-half the probability
one-half it will lower their hand it has
parallels independence so if you take
any two configurations a and B the
events a
satisfy X and B satisfy attacks are
independent it is useful to get your
statistical guarantees on the approach
so the effect is like these you start
maybe with 50 non-empty or sort of
nonzero weight assignment you add a
parity constraint about half of them
disappear then you add another one and
half disappear another one another one
another one until you're left with I say
a unique solution or no solutions and
then you return to to the number of
rounds that it took you two to get to
the point now remember that what we
wanted to do is to do it for weighted
problems we had this probability
distribution it's not just 0 1 it turns
out that a very similar approach works
also in decades what you do is you still
odd parity constraints but instead of
checking had every round whether there
is still somebody with their hands up
but there's still somebody survives what
you do is you find the assignment with
the highest weight so you find the mode
of the distribution that you're left
with after you add the parity constraint
you sort of that if the weights are all
0 1 is sorry it's a very difficult it's
a very difficult problem yeah it's an
optimization problem that can be that
can be hard it's especially easier than
counting but it's still potentially a
hard problem it's a combinatorial
optimization problem and but by
repeating this procedure are certain
number of times you are able to deduct
something about the model count
but a total weight which is what we
wanted to compute the picture is like
this we start with a function here that
we want to integrate basically what you
do is you first find the mode of this
function then you add one random parity
constraint that will basically throw
away half of the configurations and you
find the mode of what's left you repeat
this process a small number of times
finding the mode which iteration then
you compute some statistic of that in
this case the median then you do the
same thing with to parity constraints so
you specify the state space even more
and you repeat it a bunch of times and
you aggregate taking a median and you
repeat this for different number of
constraints and then at the end you
scale up things appropriately and it
turns out that this will be the final
estimate for the total weight what is in
what is n n is the number of variables
that could be up to two to the ends or a
possible
so it turns out that you can prove some
strong guarantees on the accuracy of
this algorithm it will compute a
constant factor approximation to the
total weight and it requires solving a
relatively small number of optimization
problems and you can get down to sort of
like a 1 plus epsilon approximation by
adding more variables or there are other
tricks to to do that if you if you want
but for now that's just just building up
to our original problem of trying to
combine random projections with light
projection the idea is that we are going
to think of these random parity
constraints as some kind of random
projection that we can apply to these
complex objects that are probability
distributions so we start with some
probability distribution looks like this
then we add this parity constraint this
randomness this random perturbation if
you wish and then we get a new
probability distribution that is in some
sense simpler because of the properties
because of pairwise independence and
because this is a universal hash
function in some sense this / this
projection preserves a lot of the
information as we have seen before in
some sense by don't lose too much
information you can still recover the
total weight of the original problem by
solved by just looking at the mode of
this randomly projected problems we got
a formula as an ocean is simpler less
degrees of freedom less variables
basically every constraint removes one
degree of freedom so brings down the
entropy that's sort of one way to think
about why do I projection the wide
approximation works
so there were intuitive way to think of
it is that this random projection
simplifies the model and preserves the
key properties so now how are we going
to use this how much time do I have so
are we going to use it with the
variational inference remember the basic
idea is that we start with P and we want
to project it down to some tractable
family and in general these KL
divergence can be very large so am I not
the approximation might not be good so
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to first take a random projection
by adding disparity constraints and then
we are going to take on I projection so
we're going to solve this we're going to
find the best approximation of the
randomly projected model using this
tractable family and the intuition is
that if the unlock position good
question yeah so I'm sort of glossing
over it you need to find the right
number as usual
the key thing here to note is that if Q
this family is sufficiently expressive
in the sense that it contains all the
generate probability distributions so
all probability distributions that put
all the probability mass in one point
like Tinker it Dirac Delta is kind of
kind of things then you can sort of see
why this approximation should work well
right because before we were
approximating the random projection the
randomly projected model just by looking
at the mode of the distribution just as
with a single point right before when we
were doing this approach we were every
time we would just apply let's see if I
have it we would apply a projection and
then find a mode so we'll just look at a
single state with the highest
probability now well now as you can
imagine you can always recover that
approximation by choosing one of these
degenerate distributions that put all
the probability mass at one point but if
you're tractable family is even larger
than your approximation can all get
worse if you're finding the optimal
approximation and if indeed the optimal
approximation has to choose just a
single point you can always do it but by
looking at a larger set of the larger
set of options the approximation can
only improve yeah you just have the
degenerate sir do you have say of finite
accommodations because that's the
structure of these projections right
it's a finitely supported set and if you
do enough projections you might have a
small number then there is no high
projection would be exact yes but then
the variance could be huge so we've
always want to control the variance or
when I get something that works with
high probability so we just need the
extreme states
so then basically the algorithm works
like before what you do is you repeat a
small number of random projections and
then you can find the corresponding I
projection and then you aggregate and
you can show that this will give you up
well a good approximation with high
probability if you choose carefully the
right number of parity constraints
throughout this what's the advantage of
these that when it is that as we said
basically this random projection
preserves a lot of the information so we
don't lose much by doing that and
advantage of our previous approaches is
that now this approximation here this
variational optimization problem is
actually a continuous one yeah just
understand let's say that my original
distribution was the uniform
distribution for the satisfying
assignments of a CNF yeah so what is the
first step dude what is the second step
uniform so you would basically add I
just want something my distribution so
it would work very similarly to the
standard model counting thing except
that at every step instead of checking
satisfiability you would try to solve
this variational optimization problem
what I must Lee is what is the final
result that I get I'll in terms of
approximation gallo what should it look
like it will if you can do it which I
mean I'm gonna come to the bars of the
catch because there is no of course
there's no magic but ideally it would
find you in that case it will find you
one a satisfying assignment will put all
the probability mass on that one God you
take and make sure this is that right
each drawn roughly
well you do need a few of them just to
get statistical guarantees
yeah how many clear conditions on the
set of travel distributions I mean will
you say you have the extreme ones but
nothing in the queen of it no it just
has to be like what we use is mean field
so fully factored distributions which
includes the degenerate points for
example that's basically the only one
we've played with in practice which is
why that people use often also the final
aggregation step is sort of like you are
closing in some sense at that stage you
are scaling up more like you're sort of
getting a media and then scaling up so
it's the same aggregation of what we
were doing before but I guess the key
point I wanted to make here is that this
optimization problem is now a continuous
one we don't have combinatorial
optimization anymore this is an
optimization problem over probability
distributions and so you can find some
parameterization of those and you're
solving a continuous optimization
problem so for example if we look at
mean field where the approximating
family is fully factored then we get a
randomly projected mean field problem
which is nice in the following sense
it's coordinate wise concave so if you
fix all the variables except for one in
that variable is concave so you can sort
of do coordinate ascent methods or you
can look at gradients you can do all
sort of interesting things on that
objective it has less variables which is
also nice the challenges that is still
non convex so this is the catch this is
where there is no free lunch finding the
best approximation the best mean field
approximation is a non convex
optimization problem so in general we
are not going to get guarantees we don't
know how to solve non convex
optimization problems but if you have a
way to find the global up to if you can
really find the best approximation then
you get good accuracy guarantees it
becomes an empirical think of actually
finding that
I'm out of time 0 ok sounds good just
show you it does work well in practice
like see if you compared to play mean
field you can get maybe five hundred
orders of magnitude improvement by using
these kind of random projections it
works on these kind of deep learning
models you can get better more accurate
estimates of partition function with
respect to mean field you can use it to
learn generative models so you can use
it in this complex models where you have
neural networks that sort of generate
the data and you use other neural
networks to sort of specify the
approximating family and use it and it
works well like you can learn models you
can do denoising and while other kinds
of random projections I'm going to skip
this part and just conclude so yeah
hopefully I convinced you that you know
you can use random projections for
probabilistic inference they've been
used a lot in information retrieval
machine learning to speed up a lot of
useful tasks and I think you can't but
it's very exciting to look at ways to
use them in probabilistic inference and
learning you can come up with new
algorithms with provable guarantees and
then improve practical performance and
there are very exciting applications in
machine learning like learning
generative models of data in an
unsupervised way to choose priority
functions with with many variables why
college
punctuated with Levi battled one make
life easier yes sir if you did one what
you get is you can get an unbiased
estimator so if you'd do with one and
you repeat it a very large number of
times you can get your right answer the
problem is that what we want here we
always want to only do it a small number
of times we want to control the variance
okay any parameter that is a number of X
0 para ver SI yes you can call it turns
out you can control the variance as a
function of how long the parity
constraints are it turns out you can
actually get shorter than n over 2 you
can actually get some kind of guarantees
even using non parity functions that's
the kind of thing I've skipped but we
have a nice EML paper where we show what
you can do if you start with any kind of
circuit your favorite circuit here and
then you build a hash function but
basically randomly wiring the inputs
into the circuit and randomly choosing
an output so we have a way to sort of
analyze how well this will work as a
hash function it turns out that the key
property is something called annoy
sensitivity it's something good for a
spectrum of the function but you can
work out how well they will work in more
general cases
that's Dmitri he has a paper on using
error correcting codes yeah yeah if you
would compare wish which does the MDE
exactly with this just proximate what
happens if you compare is so if you
can't get em pé exactly then you get a
better you good yeah you might as well
go for that in both cases one needs more
time one is more approximately so the
advantage is that you can you get a
continuous optimization problem that's
the way I see it and you can plug in
neural network and you can do
interesting things like you can use
amortize the infrared you can do like
where you'd sort of using you can sort
of store the computations that I've done
in dealer named model you can sort of
use the computation that you have done
in coming up with a good approximating
family over and over and you can sort of
train at the same time a generative
model and a good recognition network
that will basically come up with a good
approximation for the posterior so
that's the key advantage so you can sort
of plug it in into some of the almost
well state-of-the-art architectures to
learn this generative models of images
and data so going back to my questions
in the experiments how do you decide how
many excellent split so in the
experiments we actually let me see in
the in the generative models we just
picked a number that was showing sort of
lacking cross-validation picking a
number that worked well in the rbm I
think we did an exhaustive search and we
found the one that worse that was giving
the best bounty just two numbers and you
cannot say anything about the other
entities we cannot say anything anyways
because of the you can get lower bounds
the problem is that if there is a non
convex optimization problem that we
don't know how to get a certificate of
optimality so the only thing we can get
our lower bounds and we still get the
lower bounds with the short parity
constraints or a fixed number of parity
constraints
so if I understand correctly you showed
us a way how to approximate the value of
the log-likelihood at a certain theta
but you really want is to optimize over
theta yeah you're using this as a
subroutine and say gradient descent
perhaps adding having a noisy estimate
we make the gradient descent problem how
do you see any of that in practice
practice of work so this is like a
learning a variational out encoder where
you have basically random noise fed
through neural network that produces
images and then you use another neural
network to sort of come up with an
approximation for the posterior taking
the images input and coming up with the
parameters and then you do the random
projection at that step a bunch of times
when you use that to basically as on
another another approximation for the
marginal likelihood and it works better
than without like if you do the noising
this is what you get without the random
projection this is what you get with the
random projection so here the task is
sort of like I give you a corrupted
digit and you try to reconstruct it and
there are a few examples where the
standard model doesn't work like a three
is completed to a nine and our thing
actually gives you a three it surely
indicates that is doing a better job we
are running
you might live in 10